my name is Tim vibha I'm the business
and technology editor of BBC News
interactive the main thing that my team
and I do is a BBC news websites Business
and Technology Bader's and I've been
told that nobody has tried to answer
this one key question what is the main
reason by yochelson crisis and I give it
a shot and not quite sure I can really
explain it in that great detail because
a lot of things that have gone wrong the
main reason though I think is something
I don't cook or irrational exuberance
when it comes to sorting out your
finances what have you got in with God
households that get cheap credit that
think Oh everything is good and who do
not know the meaning of the word down
that things could slow down as a result
of that and they take out mortgages they
take out loans now I'm not talking that
much about government's a lot of
governments got that wrong as well but
we're not talking about households this
is the biggest problem household debt in
quite a number of countries exploded and
because it exploded hello we need more
salaries in higher salaries so they
demanded higher salaries and the
companies are all were you getting cheap
credit as well so yes we pay our work as
much which moment and suddenly you've
got this real spiral of junk of the cost
of employing people allowances and
people taking one more debt because they
only have my seller is going up there I
can take on even more debt and then
comes the crunch point when this
suddenly stalls you will find out that
because your salary and afterward you're
not competitive anymore people
especially not competitive against
Germany because in Germany they didn't
do this germany which was probably your
biggest competitor it was in the
European Union
they kept greatest right absolutely flat
for nearly a decade while in Spain Italy
in Greece another country's Portugal
Ireland wages exploded and people made
really irrational buying decisions
lending decisions buying decisions when
I saw lending decisions now we come to
the second problem of course which are
the banks the banks say oh well it's
easy good money it's cheap to get money
so we are very happy to give money to
people who frankly one portion give
money to where they don't properly think
about the risk they have any ending and
also whether banks don't copy you think
about the risks they have in borrowing
money we're more more corporation it's
not financed by the savings have been
but they go to the money markets because
their money is plentiful and money's
cheap what if something triggers that
this money disappears then you get the
exact equivalent of what happens when
you play as dominoes and you tip one of
those dominoes and one after the other
force now you can delay at every level
you can do that with mortgages as we've
seen with a subprime crisis in the
United States of them I'm straight into
Europe using that with Greece we're in
one country girls gets into trouble and
then you have the domino effect for all
the other countries very well they have
a similar situation so that there's an
issue and and then you get a really
vicious circle where one bit of bad news
accelerates in other and it's very
difficult to stop this downward spiral
if you can't stop the downward spiral
then you get a long term crisis have you
put a floor into this pipe and tube into
the whole thing no I don't think I said
yeah I think it will be quite some time
to wear anywhere close to this but we
may have just right now but a few
firewalls in that hopefully calms things
a little bit down so i think it was
exuberant people are thinking about risk
not thinking about the future properly
for consumers for banks for companies a
lot of people guilty and when people say
no it's the banks is it it's a banks
etsy consumers they're always quite a
lot of fingers pointing it yourself when
you do that that's that would happen
everybody got it wrong and everybody was
very very careless and that's why we're
in the mess we are